Boris Johnson brought the biggest name
in Natural History to publicize a
crucial UN climate change conference in
the UK later this year David
Attenborough heard him promise that by
the time this audience has grown up
carbon emitting cars will be on their
way out
from 2035 new petrol and diesel cars
will be banned and electric models like
this will become the norm that's five
years earlier than planned and today
finding power is far from routine this
may be part of the answer pop up
Chargers trialed on a street in Oxford
its 2035 deliverable I think it's 100%
achievable however one thing we've
really got to remember is that there are
millions of households particularly in
urban areas that will not use an
electric vehicle because they can't
charge conveniently at home overnight
for all the sophistication of modern
cars they're still relying on technology
that's 150 years old now in just 15 the
government wants to consign the internal
combustion engine to the scrap heap and
crucially that includes hybrids until
now the industry's best answer to cut in
carbon last year two point 1 million new
petrol and diesel cars were registered
in the UK that compares to just under
38,000 fully battery-powered electric
vehicles another 191,000 hybrids either
plug-in or self charging were also
registered but from 2035 these will be
obsolete
Tesla transformed the top-end of the
electric market but mass producers have
been slow to keep up there are fewer
than 100 fully electric cars available
in the UK and prices remained beyond the
reach of many drivers the industry
maintains only public subsidy can close
the gap you actually need targets for
incentives we need to be told that there
will be a plug-in grant you know for the
next 10 years we need to be told there
will be cuts in v80 there will be tax
breaks if we're not told that then it
will still be cloud cuckoo-land sky
owner of Sky News has pledged to make
its fleet of 5 thousand vehicles
all-electric to help it hit a target of
net zero carbon by 2030
the corporations and consumers change is
inevitable and will be felt in every
home and on every street poor Kelso Sky
News